foreign
indyke I'm the chief projectionist here
at the IMAX theater at the Indiana State
Museum
we have the largest screen in the state
it's 60 feet tall 84 feet wide and when
we run IMAX film The portions of the
film that were shot with IMAX cameras
fill that screen entirely we are
thrilled to welcome all of you here for
the opening night of Christmas
this is print number 25 of Oppenheimer
in IMAX film it arrived in 53 reels that
I spliced together over the course of
three days I love handling films so I
really enjoy the process of putting
together the film
it's 70 millimeter film so the frame
size is about that big that's three
times the size of regular 70 millimeter
and about 10 times the size of 35
millimeter which is what was in most
theaters before they switched to digital
because of the frame size it's going
about 350 feet per minute it goes
through a lot of film very fast I'm told
it's about 11 miles long
unrolled and actually this film is the
longest IMAX film ever we had to put
extensions on the platters to be able to
fit it the maximum length we could play
before was about 2 hours and 48 minutes
and this one is slightly over three
hours that size is what makes this
experience here are unique at least
among the 30 theaters that are showing
it that way my first experience with
film that really changed the way I
looked at it was seeing 2001 in a
Cinerama Theater when it came out in 68
that was a formative experience for me
it changed what I thought movies could
be was much more of an experience than
just watching a show IMAX is kind of a
continuation of that it's a big screen
it's a massive experience and it's so
much more than what you're gonna see if
you watch it on TV at home